tatsächlich sind die Strom- und
Gaspreise gesunken und wir haben alle so
den Eindruck das war's jetzt aber wir
müssen feststellen Ursachen war der
milde Winter es waren natürlich auch die
noch weiter laufende Kernkraftwerke auch
die Kohlekraftwerke wurden ja einige
hinzu geschaltet das hat alles zu
Entspannung beigetragen aber wir haben
nach wie vor noch doppelt so hohe
Strompreise wie 21 und wir haben noch
viermal so hohe Strompreise wie unsere
Wettbewerber USA und China
heute hat Deutschland weltweit die
höchsten Strompreise der Welt
hinter Burkina Faso Nr 2
also die richtige Energiekrise kommt
noch steht uns bevor es wird bitter
denn erst gehen die Kernkraftwerke vom
Netz dann im nächsten Frühjahr die
ersatzkraftwerke mit Braunkohle und
Steinkohle und dann wird es ein böses
Erwachen geben der Bundeskanzler der
Bundesregierung hat gesagt ja wir bauen
jetzt demnächst fünf Windräder am Tag
und damit wird das Problem dann gelöst
es wird es nicht lösen wir wissen ja
Windkraftwerke liefern an 140 Tagen des
Jahres nun mal gerade eben
na Null sind stehen sie liefern die
keinen Strom und dieses Problem will die
Bundesregierung lösen indem sie 40
Gaskraftwerke
Gaswerke da von dem wir ja nicht letztes
Jahr noch gehört haben wir haben eine
Gaskrise
zum Ersatz bauen und dann sagt man ja
dann machen wir am Wasserstoff nicht man
muss wissen wir haben wieder
elektrolyseure wir haben nicht die
Leitung es gibt nicht nur mal
wasserstoffturbinen und am Ende wird das
viermal so teuer und deswegen was uns
Kanzler Scholz nicht sagt ist wir
steuern in eine lang anhaltende
stromkrise und sie wird Deutschland
viele viele Arbeitsplätze kosten dann
gibt es die Lösung des grünen Chefs der
Bundesnetzagentur der sagt naja das
nennt er last-management aber das
Lastmanagement heißt ich stelle euch den
Strom ab le Autos sollen abgestellt
werden dann sollen die Wärmepumpen
abgestellt werden die Strom intensive
Industrie denn so könnte man dann den
Zusammenbruch verhindern aber das ist
Entwicklungsland das ist Mark
Entwicklung sondern sowas macht man in
Südafrika aber noch nicht in Deutschland
meine Alternative die habe ich im diesen
Buch jetzt formuliert ist wir brauchen
Förderung des eigenen Erdgases wir
müssen nicht aus Amerika zu schlechten
Konditionen
Erdgas importieren wir haben es selber
unter unseren Füßen
wir können auch Kohlekraftwerke mit
CO2-Abscheidung machen unsere eigene
Braunkohle nutzen aber das CO2 rausholen
und damit auch China und Indien zeigen
dass man sowas umweltfreundlich machen
kann und am Ende
es ist leider vergeblich lasst doch die
Kernkraftwerke so lange laufen wie wir
sie brauchen und das Sagen übrigens 70%
der deutschen
der Kanzler hat im Wahlkampf gesagt wir
wollen einen Strompreis von 4 € wir
haben jetzt 11 12 dreifache und wenn wir
das nicht hinkriegen und wenn er das
nicht hinkriegt wird die Strom in Strom
intensive Industrie in Deutschland keine
Zukunft haben keine Zukunft das klingt
nach dem ganz bitteren Urteil also
machen das einmal konkret wo sehen Sie
die deutsche Industrien wenn es jetzt so
weitergeht in zwei Jahren was bedeutet
das für die Arbeitsplätze die
Automobilindustrie die ist jetzt schon
am stöhnen viele Industrie in der
wandern ab und wollen woanders
produzieren planen das auch meinen Sie
uns einmal müssen wir uns alle stellen
das schreckliche das dunkle Szenario aus
wenn jetzt nichts passiert was glauben
Sie naja es gehört über fünf Millionen
Arbeitsplätze die daran hängen und das
sind ja Wertschöpfungsketten das ist ja
man kann ja sagen okay müssen wir
unbedingt Aluminium in Deutschland
machen aber wenn man Aluminium weglässt
dann haben wir da auch den
Aluminiumblock des Motors weg und man
hat beim man das Kupfer nicht mehr macht
auch die Wicklung für den Elektromotoren
nicht mehr im Lande das heißt das
Brechen die ganzen Kaskaden der
Entwickler der der Kette weg und
deswegen ist das so gefährlich das ähm
überschätzt man häufig dass wenn man da
ein Stein aus der Mauer fällt zieht das
sind die gesamte Mord zusammenfällt sie
können nicht einfach in einem Chemiewerk
sagen ach dann mache ich jetzt keinen
Ammoniak mehr oder ich mache jetzt nur
noch Kerosin das andere mache ich aber
nicht das funktioniert so nicht weil wir
sind eine Wirtschaft die so verzahnt ist
wo die wirklich
miteinander verknüpft ist da mache ich
mir wirklich große Sorgen und ich glaube
wir haben es noch in der Hand
das zu lösen aber es gehören jetzt ein
paar Wahrheiten auf den Tisch und die
Wahrheit heißt wir müssen jetzt erstmal
das Angebot erweitern wir dürfen uns
nicht darauf verlassen
auf Gasimporte stehen sie vor was wir
gemacht haben im letzten Jahr wir haben
die Gaspreise hochgejagt weil wir
wollten ja nicht wieder zurück in die
Kohle und dann haben wir Pakistan und
Bangladesch und anderen das Gas
weggekauft was haben die jetzt gemacht
pakistan hat gesagt der Gaspreis ist für
uns jetzt so hoch durch die deutschen
und anderen hochgetrieben durch einen
Weg wir bauen jetzt nur noch
Kohlekraftwerke die bauen jetzt
Kohlekraftwerk aus denen wir jetzt
aussteigen wollen mit eurem Erdgas ja
der Wirtschaftsminister war ein Katar
hat gesagt wir brauchen nur für 5 Jahre
dann wollen wir alles in Wasserstoff man
ist natürlich totaler Blödsinn ich weiß
nicht wer ihm das erzählt hat das ist
ein Märchen von den Grünen dürfte sie
das ja nicht wundern da stand ja auch
ganz klar in der Programm da weiß man
aber wie überrascht sind sie von ihrer
eigenen SPD dass man da an der
Energiewende auch weiter fährt
jetzt langsam an
wichtig die DGB-Vorsitzende sagt jetzt
zum ersten Mal ich warne Form
Zusammenbruch der deutschen Industrie
das ist ja schon mal was aber liebe DGB
Vorstandsvorsitzende warnen reicht nicht
es muss dann auch ein Vorschlag
herkommen und der ist unangenehm ich
weiß das wenn wir jetzt sagen lass uns
doch unser eigenes Erdgas fördern wir
können das übrigens viel besser als sie
Amerikaner die Amerikaner lassen nämlich
die die Bohrlöcher offen und dann geht
das Erdgas hinterher noch raus und das
ist ja klimaschädlich außerdem verlieren
wir 25%
beim Transport das ist auch viel teurer
aber was will natürlich an Deutschland
deswegen keiner weil wir eine riesige
Angst davor haben wenn wir ein eine
erdgasbohrung in Niedersachsen
Sachsen-Anhalt wo wir wirklich für die
nächsten 20 30 Jahre eigenes preiswertes
Erdgas haben wir das machen dann wissen
wir was passiert dann klebt sich am
nächsten Tag Ende Gelände da an den
sportturm und da wir sind nicht mehr in
der Lage das dann durchzusetzen das ist
das große Problem und es wird dann die
die Medien werden sagen ja man muss doch
auch verstehen und so ist dann nein wir
müssen jetzt langsam begreifen dass wir
uns unser Schicksal selbst in die Hand
nehmen müssen und ich wünsche mir dass
der Kanzler sich mehr von Ingenieuren
und Energietechniker beraten lässt und
sich nicht irgendwelche Flöhe ins Ohr
setzen lässt von Frau lang oder vom
spd-generalsekretär das das fehlt jetzt
oder von einem Kühnert und von Frauen
nicht und niemanden der Wirtschaft geht
schlimm genug wir haben durch die
energiepreiskrise schon mal einen
Nachteil gegenüber unseren Wettbewerbern
in China und in den USA und jetzt kommen
noch Diskussion über Steuerung das ist
Gift das ist gut weg aus Deutschland für
viele natürlich äh das ist ja schon
angefangen
investiert ihn in China Daimler Benz hat
die Motoren Produktion nach China
verlagert und das offene ist das hilft
dem Klima überhaupt nicht wenn wir das
hier kaputt machen dort in China das zu
produzieren wird mit einem viel höheren
CO2-Ausstoß verbunden weil die ihre
Energie eben zum überwiegenden Teil aus
Kohle machen dass er besonders
klimaschädlich ist
wenn man das jetzt hört wenn man auch
sieht was mit unter unserer Industrie
passieren können lachen sie sich doch
kaputt der ist doch Deutschland mit
seiner Wirtschaftskraft immer
unbedeutender und somit doch auch immer
weniger ernst zu nehmen die deutsche
Wirtschaft wird ernst genommen deswegen
wird die auch noch Amerika gelochten die
Schwäche die wir jetzt haben ja wir
müssen den Preis zahlen jetzt dieses
energiekrieges wird harmlos ausgenommen
gar nicht so gut weil er eben wenig
fokussiert ist aber bei beiden macht es
jetzt mit dem sogenannten
reduction Act also hier funktioniert und
da haben sich schon viele anlocken
lassen irgendwann werden wir vielleicht
keine Energie Probleme mehr haben weil
wir keine Industrie mehr haben die
Energie braucht wir haben teilweise
schon diese perfekte also da wird viel
abgeworben im Namen der Reduzierung der
Inflation aber das größere Problem
glaube ich dass nicht nur uns sondern
auch Amerika und damit auch die ganze
Welt betrifft ist dass wir auf einem ja
sehr dünnen Eis uns bewegen wir hatten
bereits nach zwei sieben acht die
älteren von uns erinnern sich noch und
die noch nicht so alt sind dass Sie sich
noch erinnern wissen dass wir damals in
der Wirtschaft zum Finanzkrise haben
also seitdem haben wir das ganze Problem
nur verzögert durch Geld drucken wir
mussten jetzt mit Geld drucken aufhören
in dem Moment wo Inflation reinkam
Inflation wurde durch Corona durch das
Trennen der Wertschöpfungsketten
befeuert durch den Wirtschaftskrieg den
Trump mit den Chinesen vom Zahn
gebrochen hat und jetzt auch durch den
energiekrieg also wir müssen aufpassen
dass die Notenbanken jetzt nicht allzu
sehr auf die Bremse steigen müssen um
die Inflation einzudämmen weil dann
nämlich des Kartenhaus under Wall Street
in Frankfurt egal wo zusammenbricht ich
glaube wir haben noch nicht begriffen
dass wir seit vielen Jahren jetzt
Probleme nicht wirklich gelöst haben nur
weiter geschoben haben das ganze spitzt
sich zu es gibt einige die von der
Wirtschaft sehr viel mehr verstehen als
ich die hier Alarmglocken läuten die
ähnlich wie vor zwei sieben zwei acht
auch nicht gehört wurden also es kann
durchaus sein dass wir eine massive
Korrektur haben auch mit China ist nicht
alles ausgemacht das haben wir ganz
außen vorgelassen ich glaube China
spielt hier auch eine ganz große Rolle
auch was die Ukraine angeht da gibt's
jetzt Friedensangebote und auch wieder
Aufbauhilfen die die Europäer sicher
gerne in Anspruch nehmen wenn die
Amerikaner kein Bares mehr rüber wachsen
lassen sie sagen ja der Geld haben in
Amerika wird ewig offen sein vielleicht
auch deswegen weil man das eigene Geld
drucken kann und es nie zurückzahlen
können wird und auch muss vielleicht
sollten wir als sehr ähnlich handeln und
uns selber auch mal in der eigenen
Währung in Euro Verschulden aber wir
haben jetzt gerade die These auch gehört
was mit unserer Wirtschaft passieren
könnte Strompreise auf Platz zwei
Hinterburg China Phase wäre das in den
USA eine Situation wo die Menschen auf
die Straße gehen würden ja natürlich
also ich meine diese
kitchentable Politik in USA ist sehr
wichtig und ich gebe Herrn Renault
absolut Recht in seine Einschätzung das
könnte ich alles unterschreiben was er
hier gerade erzählt hat und ich glaube
wenn man so ein bisschen brain hat dann
hat man diesen Durchblick und ich rede
hier in Deutschland mit vielen Leuten
und die sind alle der Meinung ähm und
ich frage mich nur wer hat diese
Regierung oder die Grünen eigentlich
gewählt das ist für mich nach
unverständlich und übrigens in ihrer
Richtung wissen sie man braucht niemand
zu werden sondern wenn ein Unternehmen
sieht das seine Überlebenschancen sind
besser in einem Land als in dem Land wo
es gerade produziert oder ist dann geht
er in dieses Land und dank eines
subventionswettlaufs Amerika Amerika
stand mal die rohikaner ihre Partei
stand mal gegensubventionen also da
haben sie einen Pakt mit dem Teufel
jetzt das ist eine politische
Entscheidung für ich bin noch alt genug
dass ich mich noch dran erinnere gegen
Subventionen waren amerikanische
Wirtschaft es geht also auch
Infrastruktur oder andere Projekte und
ähm
wissen Sie was in Deutschland ist
sowieso jetzt Mittel war ja alles
finanziert aus Mittel das ist die ganze
Migration ist aus dem Mittelstadt des
Mittel die die Wohnungsbau soll jetzt
finanziert werden
die Industrie soll jetzt finanziert
werden die Heizkosten in Deutschland
sollen alles aus den aus den Töpfen der
das Staates finanziert da kann ich sagen
herzlichen Glückwunsch
es gibt es also amerikanische
Verhältnisse und Verschulden uns
ähnliches ich möchte ganz gerne Herrn
weinbergpflichten es sind nicht alleine
den Flaschen Inflation Act also das ist
sozusagen noch die Kaffeebohne auf der
Sahne nein es sind die Energiepreise wir
haben Energiepreise von 3 Euro Cent wir
haben Gaspreise die sind ein Drittel so
groß wie bei uns und das hält ein
Unternehmen auf Dauer nicht aussehen ich
müsste ja gegen denjenigen in Wettbewerb
treten denn nun Drittel der
Energiekosten hat
ähm kannst du nicht gewinnen und wenn du
dann noch so blöd bist und so bescheuert
bist wie das ist nicht nur Deutschland
aber vor allen Dingen Deutschland sich
die eigene Automobilindustrie kaputt
machen zu lassen man muss sich mal
vorstellen wir haben eine Stromknappheit
wir wissen wie Ihre Rennen ihn eine
stromnappheit und in dem Moment sagt das
Europäische Parlament und der
Europäische Rat wir wollen die Benzin
Autos abschaffen was brauchen die denn
ja die brauchen Strom in dieser
Situation setzen wir sozusagen noch eins
drauf in der Verschärfung und im übrigen
kostet es unsere Arbeitsplätze von in
den Firmen die die besten Autos der Welt
gebaut haben
ich etwas ändern es muss was passieren
sie haben in Ihrem Buch sind glaube ich
20 Punkte wie Sie aufgelistet haben
dafür haben wir nicht ganz Zeit aber ich
möchte zumindest wissen welche drei
Punkte sind die dringendsten Punkte was
muss jetzt angepackt werden damit wir
dieses dunkle Szenario dass wir hier
gezeichnet haben eben nicht haben werden
in schon abziehbarer Zeit gut die drei
Punkte sind erstens wir brauchen eigenes
Erdgas und wir müssen weg von dieser
Negativbild von Fracking da man darf ja
nicht vergessen dass die gesamte
deutsche Politik und die Medien auf
Putin reingefallen sind denn der soll 80
Millionen in deutsche
Initiativen und europäischen Initiativen
gesteckt haben damit sie das Fracking
Gas schlecht machen es gab so Filme wo
dann aus dem Wasserhahn das schwarze
Wasser es verboten den richtig gesteuert
worden ja und wir müssen endlich mal
sehen dass wir das entzaubern und hier
nicht reinfahren und dass wir selber
besser machen das zweite ist wir haben
eigene gute
Kohle und die müssen wir sauber machen
dann bringen wir der Welt einen
unglaublichen Beitrag wir klauen den
anderen nicht mehr das Gas weg sondern
wir machen das aus unserem eigenen
Kohlenstoff und das dritte wir brauchen
natürlich mehr Energieforschung wir
müssen wieder junge Menschen ermutigen
sie nicht irgendwo an die Straße zu
kleben sondern zu lernen zu leisten und
etwas Neues zu entdecken zu forschen das
muss wieder Spaß in Deutschland machen
und das wird alles mit ihrer SPD
gelingen da bin ich noch nicht so ganz
von überzeugt aber ich arbeite daran auf
jeden Fall ganz genau wo sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
für Sie